hey everyone this is Kevin from the Tish
website calm so they're gonna be
starting our coverage of the 2015
Sinquefield Cup just gonna be absolutely
ridiculous tournament we have nine of
the top ten players in the world
we have magnus carlsen vision on top
blob Nakamura Fabien our Caruana who won
last year and had a crazy run seven wins
in a row to start that tournament
against the best players in the world
even then we have an H Giri we have
Wesley so Alexander Gurley shook and
Levon Aronian going to be just Hunza fun
for the next two weeks we're gonna have
as many games covered as possible but
really looking forward to this
tournament it's been on my radar all
year the strongest tournament that I can
remember so really excited to have such
a strong field today we're gonna be
starting off with Nakamura burst vision
on Nakamura is my pick to win this
tournament mostly just because he's been
on a tear all year be pretty cool this
tournament is in st. Louis Missouri so I
think be pretty fun to have an American
actually win this tournament so Nakamura
so I kind of look through the field of
Americans I think he has the strongest
chance and he's been playing really
really well does have a tough tough task
to go against vision on in round number
one
but without further ado we'll go ahead
and get started Nakamura starts out with
pawn to d4 a knight f6 pawn c4 pawn East
six and then Knight to f3 trying to
avoid the nimzo-indian defense with
Knight to c3 a bishop here to be for a
non plays dish as well as anyone
Nakamura decides to just not go down
that line just doesn't want to have to
play against it as white so instead two
plays Knight to f3 pawn d5 upon to a g3
a Bishop ear to e7 getting ready to
castle on the kingside a bishop here to
g2 and this is going into the cattle and
opening we're white really trying to
control the light squares has his bishop
here on g2 really trying to put a lot of
pressure on this long diagonal right
here
Black's gonna have a few options if
Vietnam wants to take this material here
on c4 you can really just try to hang on
to this material this is gonna be
somewhat difficult to really promote
really do anything develop on the
inside White's gonna have a easy time
kind of controlling this queenside here
it's kind of open up force pieces also
this light square bishop here on g2
really just controls this nicely so non
can either take this on c4 or can decide
to not take this right away
can always play Knight to c6 you know if
there ever is an exchange that's fine we
kind of open up this efile right here
but really still controls the certain of
the board with his knight on c6 much
slower game for both sides above vision
on does have that option as well so in
the game I will see castle castle and
then pawn taking here on c4 so vision on
decides hey I'm gonna go ahead and take
through material I'll try to hang onto
it as much as I can and then just do my
best to go ahead and develop on a D
queenside Nakamura continues with Queen
to c2 threatening to capture this pawn
here on c4 pawn a6 getting ready to push
forward with pawn to b5 a few ways Y can
attack this could just take with this
Queen right here that's completely fine
another option is what Nakamura plays
and that's pawn to a4 both stopping this
and also just kind of an aggressive play
here making sure that his opponent never
really gets any traction over here on
the Queen side definitely the way that I
like to approach it as well
a bishop here to d7 I usually see and
myself will play Knight to c6 this makes
logical sense to me getting your Knights
involved into the action trying to
control the ser and the board so this is
what I usually will see happen pawn to
b6 is fine Bishop here to b7 trying to
control this long light tour diagonal
against White's button machine on
decides to go and try something
different Bishop here to d7 now the
Queen takes here on c4 equalizing in
material Bishop here to c6 so a lot of
moves from this light square Bishop
right here
Bishop up here to a g5 pinning down this
Knight to the bishop now another move
kind of somewhat surprising just to see
this Bishop kind of moving all over the
place but bishop here to d5 kicking the
Queen back and then Bishop here to e4
just kind of moving it along Nakamura
says okay I'll go ahead and retreat my
queen back here to d1 it looks like you
mean business and you're going to just
move
Bishop all over the place upon to see
five machine instill had multiple
options he still could have played the
knight to c6 didn't have to be pretty
aggressive but decided to go ahead and
kind of bust things open recognizing
that he needs to make something happen
on the queenside here so a pawn to c5
capture and then the Bishop recaptures
here on c5 so really doing a good job of
controlling the center of the board with
his bishops right now now we do see an
exchange here on d8 and the knight here
- d2 so if we kind of look at it just
kind of recapping where we're at both
sides have both their Knights both their
bishops the pawn chains are exactly the
same on board so really I would this is
about as close to an even match as
possible so it will be interesting to
see how both sides are gonna continue
you usually want your rooks in these
open files so the C and the D file
protecting that's going to be very
important
this Knight right here not really doing
much right now Nakamura decided to go
ahead and get his involved into the game
so getting this night here on ba it's
gonna be very important hook up these
rooks over here is gonna be very
important but beyond that it's kind of
anyone's game right now definitely still
wide open right now so we'll just see
what happens anam brings his bishop back
here to c6 a Knight to b3 threatening
this bishop bishop back here to e7
knight here to a5 besides hey if you're
gonna take my bishop I'll go ahead and
recapture with my pawn here can also
retake this at Bishop here on g5
completely okay with that not come or is
not ready to quite give up his bishop so
brisket back here at e3 95 bish back
here to d2 and the knight to b6 now it
looks interesting both the knight and
the bishop are both attacking this pawn
so when you first see bishop here to f4
it looks a little weird thinking that
this pawn could fall right away since
two attackers but it's actually a little
safer than you may think if the knight
takes here then all of a sudden the
knight could take here on c6 if we do
see recapture the rook takes here on a4
that's gonna be extremely bad if instead
the bishop takes here then all of a
sudden this bishop now here on f4 but
you wasn't here before
bishop here to c7 is going to be very
very
dead like the Bishop take here on b6 and
then this a Bishop is just kind of
hanging out if we do see the night come
here to b7 maybe protecting this night
still it's gonna be bad the rooks going
to fall rook here to d8 doesn't matter
Knight up here to b7
all of a sudden White has double rooks
can bring his rook over here to see one
going to be very very difficult for
black to kind of hold on to this you
know he just can't really hold on to
this open file right here we recover
here to see one just down too much
material knocking more work kind of run
over there
so instead we don't see that pawn fault
we see the night come here to d5 now
with the Knights gonna come up here to
e5 and then pawn to g5 pretty
interesting move very very aggressive
move from anon he definitely didn't have
to play the g5 he could always just say
hey I'm gonna go ahead and take your
Bishop here this whole time you haven't
wanted you haven't given up your double
bishop pair but I'll go ahead and take
just knight on here on f4 but instead
decides hey I'm gonna go super
aggressive play pawn here to g5 and then
Bishop back here to d2 Bishop here to f7
kick or f6 kickin the knight back here
to d3 and then pawn to a b6 so being
somewhat aggressive kicking all this
material back from nock and more and
that over here to c4 pawn to b5 now we
do see some exchanges come off the board
Bishop here to d5 we do see an exchange
off the board pawn taking here on c4
Bishop takes Bishop now comes down here
to b2 and then the rooks can come up
here to a2 so if we kind of digest and
look at everything that happened both
sides are still equal material they have
double rooks back here that they really
need to get involved into the action
double bishop pair both have a knight on
board for pawns on the King side one
pond on the Queen side not really an
advantage either when this is about as
even as you can get Bishop is just gonna
swing back here to g7 really controlling
this long dark diagonal exactly what
Bishop wants to do we're over here to
see one controlling this see
first time it's kind of gotten this rook
involved into the action none on the
other hand really needs to get his
knight involved to get his other rook
involved into the actions that's gonna
be on his mind first gonna bring his
bishop back here to eh
now I'm not up here to see five Bishop
here to f8 so nan decides to go and
really play a defensive mode if we saw
just not a few moves ago he was kind of
being the aggressor all of a sudden all
of his pieces are on the eighth-ranked
right here so just kind of in a
wait-and-see mode recognising that he
does not want to get a loss here he
still has a ton of material it's gonna
be very difficult for Nakamura to
actually find a win here so just playing
somewhat conservative right now keeping
all his pieces back Bishop here to d3
Knight here to c6 Bishop efore attacking
pinning down this Knight right here
Kings gonna come over here to f1 getting
ready if he needs to get involved into
the action rook here to a7 so exactly
what we talked about give this not
involved all of a sudden now get the
rook involved into the game night back
here to b3 opening up the door for this
rook right here on c1 to control this
open C file always important now we're
coming here to a c7 double-barreling
here you're always going to have your
rooks kind of in a single-file so they
help protect each other if you have a
queen as well you actually want the
Queen in the middle so it'd be rook
Queen and then rook those pieces really
do well together
rook over here to c2 so kind of a battle
for the C file right now a bishop here
to a d6 pawn up here to f4 and then
things just kind of get crazy we see
pawn here to f5 both sides of signing
hey we won't just want to play super
aggressive right now Bishop comes back
here to d3 and then we see Knight to b8
and this is a huge blunder from anon he
really didn't need to play Knight to b8
he had a leather a lot of other options
here rook over here to b8 makes a lot of
sense but Knight to be a he just didn't
quite calculate enough how the exchange
would go right away we see rook taking
here on c7 the rook takes we do see an
exchange right here and then after the
pawn takes here on G
I pawned recaptures Knight to c5 and
this is move that not quite sure a nun
really thought about all the way through
just too much
attacking prowess right here for this
Knights this pawn here on e6 is really
really what's tough for black to hold on
to if he wants to try to hold on to it
with his bishop then that's going to be
very very difficult it can't really come
here because then you just see an
exchange on board and then the bishop
just comes up here and takes that's
definitely gonna be bad
the bishop Tate comes here to f7 all of
a sudden the knight to a6 can't
recapture if he does she's just gonna
lose that material all of a sudden
White's still up in material as well so
just all in all really really difficult
for nan to do it just don't think you
really saw how powerful this night here
on c5 is going to be Bishop here to a d6
Knight taking here on e6 up and material
the bishop does take care on a4 but
nakamura is just gonna gain material
right here on g5 we do see a few more
moves of bishop here to d7 and then
bishop here to c3 and then
Vichy and nan decides to go ahead and
tip is king over and call it quits right
here although he is only down a pawn and
material this is in game that any Grand
Master is gonna be able to turn in to
win especially since they're all on the
Kings side of the board it's just gonna
be easy for him to overwhelm his
opponent with more material especially
pawns promote one of this pawns to Queen
and easily win the game so as you can
imagine if you've seen in a high-level
chess usually your opponent's just going
to concede in that spot and that's
exactly what Vichy non did so played
extremely well just made a huge blunder
at the end here just didn't go through
all of his calculations which for
fishing on a lot because he's really
really good at that stuff so
congratulations to Nakamura as I thought
he would he is just on fire right now
playing extremely well so
congratulations to him hopefully he
continues to do well what's really crazy
this tournament has just been up cert
already on day one we've had five
matches and we
five winners I really expected in such a
huge tournament playing in some of the
best players in the world that we would
see at least four draws I thought that
we're gonna have one win maybe we've had
five winners today which means we've had
five losers so some of the best player
in the players in the world I've already
lost but congratulations Nakamura he
sits the top of the leader standings
tied with a few others so hopefully you
guys are excited about this tournament
hopefully you enjoyed this game and keep
an eye out for more games in the future
I'll see y'all then thanks for watching